you might recognize him as the Sheriff  of Nottingham Hans Gruber or severus  snape but you've definitely seen Alan  Rickman on-screen and unfortunately we  must report that he passed away at age  69 due to cancer as mentioned you  probably know Rickman from his roles in  die hard and Robin Hood Prince of  Thieves his most famous role was  arguably Professor Snape in the Harry  Potter films to that end Harry Potter  creator JK Rowling paid her tributes on  Twitter there are no words to express  how shocked and devastated I am to hear  of Alan Rickman's death he was a  magnificent actor and a wonderful man my  thoughts are with his wife Rima and the  rest of Alan's family we have all lost a  great talent they have lost a part of  their hearts Alan Rickman will certainly  be missed and so we offer our deepest  condolences to his family from gamespot  happy trails